we have a catastrophe at our Southern
border it is because the Border has been
deliberately opened wide that we see the
the terrific Horrors that are taking
place across our country right now
here's a short list from Texas to New
York waves of illegal immigrants are now
overwhelming our communities just since
the time I was elected speaker less than
a 100 days ago more than
700,000 illegals have been welcomed into
our country illegally by the Biden
Administration American school children
have been forced into virtual schools
why so migrants can sleep in their
school buildings Korean War veterans of
the US have been booted from nursing
homes that were sold to house migrants
our streets are being flooded with fenel
hundreds of thousands of Childrens and
adults are being poisoned and losing
their lives vulnerable children and
women are being exploited and trafficked
by cartels and and that's happening even
within our Borders The Fallout goes on
and on and on and I am here this morning
to beg of my colleagues to help us Force
the administration to take action we
have to stop this now and put Americans
and Americans border security first
among those who've been apprehended on
the southern border but between ports of
Entry more than 300 individuals who are
on our Terror watch list terrorist watch
list the frightening question is if so
many terrorists were caught attempting
to cross our borders how many have
entered undetected we suspect it is a
much higher number the bid
Administration has replaced detain and
Deport with Catch and Release instead of
order they have chosen for us disorder
and Chaos rather than securing the
Homeland they've seed the Homeland to
cartels and traffickers by the way at
the at the Del Rio sector alone at Eagle
Pass Texas they told us the cartels are
they are estimated uh I think they said
they're making $3.5 million a day
trafficking human being into the country
do the math they're making over a
billion dollars a year bringing
undocumented children trafficed children
victims right into the country and and
and and and bringing them in they're
doing this intentionally they have
chosen disorder and Chaos they have
seeded the homeland of the traffickers
and the cartels and the Department of
Homeland Security has effectively become
a taxi driver to just help traffickers
complete the last few miles of their
human smuggling operation and they're
making billions of dollars in the
process it's all absolute Madness as the
president and his team continue working
to deliver a historic bipartisan
agreement On the Border House
Republicans have a choice to make they
can keep playing politics or they can
work in a bipartisan way to secure the
Border sadly this is not new for years
years they have refused to heed the
president's request for action on much
needed funding for border security for
example in the bill the president
introduced in his first day in office
more than a thousand days ago he
requested funding to develop and deploy
exped Expediting screening technology to
improve our ability to catch narcotics
and Contraband at every Port of Entry
Republicans never acted on the bill each
year in office President Biden has
requested record breaking border
security funding into to law but without
exception House Republicans have tried
to stop the president from delivering
the resources we need at the border as
recently as October President Biden
submitted a supplemental request for
additional resources for border security
House Republicans did not take it up now
house republ Republicans are going
further and signaling that they may
refuse even to consider a historic
bipartisan border security deal that
would strengthen America's national
security perhaps speaker Johnson and
House Republicans should reflect on what
they've had to say over just the past
few months in October speaker Johnson
said we must come together and address
the broken border and in November he
said I think we can get a bipartisan
agreement on border security but
suddenly we've heard a change of tune
one Republican member from Texas even
said why would they do anything to help
President Biden this is about helping
the president this is about helping the
American people it's not about helping
the president it's about the American
people this is about securing the Border
Republicans in the Senate are working
with us to do just that Republicans in
the house should as well when they said
they were going to cut the wire down
there and let them start crossing the
border again uhuh they need to close the
borders I grew up in Arizona man it was
never a problem like that this is crazy
our country is being overtaken I would
love to see Governor Landry support uh
Governor Abbott with the National Guard
with whatever resources that we can do
that we can help because really all
states in America have become a border
state we're all being seeing this influx
and being invaded as Governor avot said
it is an invasion I don't really know
how it's going to play out I just
applaud Governor Abbot's courage and the
other Governors who stood with him
hopefully it will make a difference
hopefully this is a wakeup call for
President Biden and for Congress to say
people are sick of
it